[Music]
our Series a more perfect union shows
what unites us as Americans is far
greater than what divides us co-workers
at an auto plant in Anna Ohio combined
their unique skills to literally give a
team member a hand you could say the
story is first reported by Scott light
he's anchor at CBS affiliate that's WB
NS 10 TV in Columbus Ohio well guess
who's here at the table
she's got light good morning we're glad
to have you here hi everybody I have any
color good to see you thanks for the
invite this morning welcome I want to
introduce you to some folks that you're
about to meet here who build cars not
mechanical body parts but using a
combination of old-school handiwork
high-tech engineering and relationships
around the world they built something
life-changing
each one's got a certain talent and by
their selves they could do pretty good
but when you bring a whole group of
people with different talents together
that's when things start clicking this
custom build isn't the kind you'd expect
from workers at an auto plant I would
have never dreamed when I started here
that we would ever do anything like this
this project had nothing to do with cars
so you've got tons of different
backgrounds coming together to build
something that nobody's ever that no
none of us have ever done before
something no one has done because these
Honda colleagues came together to build
an arm for fellow employee Tony Leonard
I'm gonna here four ports four cars how
am I going to build an arm I'm not a
doctor you know we've done a lot of
research on it and figured out that we
can do this
Tony suffered from a childhood spinal
condition that brought new problems in
adulthood a surgery helped strengthen
his legs but a separate rare disease
ravaged his left elbow I had gone
through about five surgeries to try to
stabilize it and none of it was working
so the decision was just go ahead and
habitated without a prosthetic arm to
offer balance tony was wheelchair bound
so his colleagues stepped in manager
Frank colleague came up with the idea
and knowing that the different
technologies that we have the scanning
and the 3d printing it was pretty
obvious to me that we were capable of
doing it kali enlisted engineer les
Bowers who assembled the right parts
this one here actually came out of a
remote-control helicopter and the right
people three servos each servo
controlling different portions of the
hand
Richard Crossan created a comfortable
stand high D'Antoni
to ensure accurate scans of both of
Tony's arms Tony Scott Jones created 3d
models and we would repeat this multiple
times until they finally got something
that worked very well for Tony
once you get to know him you would do
anything you could to help him Susie
Volos works in purchasing and used her
connections to source supplies some from
as far as Japan this is all sort of a
prototype circuit board electrical
design engineer Cory Howard brought the
prosthetics fingers to life David Mackay
also known as MacGyver became the
project's utility guy there's some
things that computers and machines can't
figure out it just takes experience and
I have the knack to be able to visualize
beforehand what something's going to
look like after a couple of months the
team's work led to this day when Tony
Leonard walked for the first time in two
years I was totally surprised how stable
I was at first I was I was excited my
adrenaline was pumping I was happy I
gotta say it was pretty emotional day it
was it was great to see him walk again
eventually Tony got a top-of-the-line
prosthetic through his insurance but
that arm had limitations attach it to
the crutch the team rallied again this
time building a special hook so Tony
could hold on to his crutches and leave
his wheelchair behind they got you out
of that chair yeah they cut me on this
chair how do you think the eyes for
doing that for you feels pretty sturdy
I like a thinking this continue to get
stronger
and use the very product they provided
for me we're not a bunch of coworkers
we're kind of a family over here and
it's good to be part of that Tony's team
built six arms each one bettering the
last so I have the fourth one in the
last one here we'll show you in a bit
Honda has a conference every year that
highlights problem solving at its
factories worldwide typically that award
goes to innovations designed for cars of
course last year though the top award
went to the team from Ohio for building
those very so which arm is this so that
was part of the last one that was won a
fourth win and so the fourth and the
sixth one so again they built him six
arms and that one that you're holding
right there in order so that's just by
the way the power of dreams that was
tattooed in that arm but that was part
of the 3d imaging because they had to
reverse-engineer from his good arm to
get something to fit his amputation you
can already see the difference so scout
between the fourth one and the last one
I'm DS at me two other workers these are
workers who work through lunch came in
early work to late at night and it's one
of those stories that's it's pure it's
it's pure engineering meets pure love it
shows you the skill of the auto worker
though they're not just somebody these
are putting widgets on the thing i've
sold that they took to do that and this
is our series the more perfect union is
about how we have more in common than we
have differences and care about one
another thank you
thank you sorry Scott light of WB NS 10
TV great to have you here